Welcome. I'm Iwana Fortuna, a product
manager in Axess and today we're going
to dive into a topic that I personally
find uncomfortable, but which most
probably development teams considered
already solved. The topic is called
architecturally ready, behaviorally
unvalidated. And today with me I have
Iwana Giza, who is an architect and who
claims that you can technically build
systems that are flawless, but still
have them fail tremendously in
production. So, Iwana, welcome and tell
us more.
Hello, Iwana. Yes, that is right and I
would add something in here. It does not
just happen that it will
it can fail. It will really fail, yeah,
quite predictably in fact and that is
the part that surprised me the most when
I started to work with agentic systems
in production.
It is not about not knowing how to
build. It is the fact that what you have
built has not been validated for what it
is about to encounter out there.
Okay, but before we dive deeper,
why is it behaviorally unvalidated and
not just simply untested? Tested means
you have run a set of scenarios, yeah,
and probably you passed that scenarios
because this is why you are in
production. Behaviorally unvalidated
means something different. It means you
have not verified how the system behaves
when the real world scenarios
are not following your test cases, yeah.
And this
is happening when a user does something
we did not anticipate, when an input
comes in a format that you were not
modeling, when a technically correct
decision it's wrong from business
perspective. So, testing verifies what
you have thought of and behavioral
validation verifies what you do not
think of.
Okay, so I'm a product manager, right?
So, let us start with the why.
Let's say you have the system, you have
the architecture, you have the
pipelines, you have the deployment.
What is missing?
What is missing is validation of what I
call the gray zone, yeah? Look, in
traditionally software development, you
have a relatively clear line.
Development, testing, production. Super
easy, yeah? In a genetic AI, there is an
intermediate zone, the zone between
product, testing, and development where
the truly dangerous things are happening
and it is a zone that very few are
willing to step into because they are
considering it just development, yeah?
Evaluations.
Okay, so why is that?
Because it involves a type of work that
do not easily recognize as work on the
product side, on the testing side, yeah?
Like I said, it's purely development and
it is not.
It is not just code.
Um
It is not an automated test, yeah? Um it
is not a Jira ticket. It is a
conversation between product owner,
developers, and someone from the
business side um
where you ask what happens when the
agent receives something
that we do not think of and the honest
answer most of the time it's we do not
know. We did not model that scenarios.
And this is the problem.
Okay, but isn't that called
insufficient testing?
No, and that is the important
distinction. We are calling them
evaluations. Everyone knows them like
this. Um, let me give you a concrete
example. We have um, a communication
agent, yeah, and in the beginning it uh,
processed conversation, generated
structured response in a JSON format.
During testing, hundreds of
conversation, everything worked
perfectly. In production, after few
weeks, parsing errors starting
appearing. Why?
Because real users
typed long conversation, emojis,
multiple languages. It was a combination
of basically everything. Even if we
evaluated it,
we were evaluating them separately, and
exactly this this was the problem.
Um, the model was doing what it was told
to do. It was a lack of behavioral
validation. We had not verified how the
system reacts to the real complexity
from the real world.
And is there anything that could have
been done to avoid these issues from
happening in production?
Yes, behavioral evaluations on input
variability. So, specifically, a set of
evaluations with real-world messages,
long, multilingual, with emojis, with
chaotic structure, where you are not
checking whether the agent uh, responds,
but whether the output it's structurally
valid, yeah? So, can the JSON be parsed?
Is the schema respected? Are the
required fields really present? So,
these are not unit tests. Uh, these are
evaluations that simulate what the agent
actually encounters in production. And
you build them uh, together with product
people, with business people, with
testers, because they know what the real
user looks like. We will come back to to
evaluations in in our discussion. They
are the bridge that ties everything.
Even if we are discussing
related to behaviorals or with reactions
of of the agent. So, what I hear is that
the system it's not poorly built, it's
just that it doesn't mirror the real
world scenario and what happens in
reality actually. Exactly and that is
frustrating because the engineering team
did evaluations, did testing, did
everything perfectly, yeah? But actually
it was not so perfectly because
not they were not taking the time to ask
what does the agent do when it receives
something completely unexpected? And the
implicit answer from the product side,
from the development side was it will
probably figure it out. Oh, yeah.
Spoiler alert, it's not figuring it out.
You mentioned something interesting a
few days ago.
You said that a system can still fail
and this failure can be invisible from a
monitoring and infrastructure
perspective. So, how does that look in
practice? Yeah. This means that your
dashboard is green, yeah? Latency is
fine, zero errors, respond code 200
okay. And yet the business level at at
the business level something is
fundamentally wrong.
Let me give you an example that
frustrate me a lot.
An assessment agent, yeah? It talked to
candidates,
evaluate responses. At one point the
candidate was giving an completely
unexpected answer. The agent attempt to
an action that did not exist and the
orchestrator caught that exception,
executed a fallback, and continued. From
a technical perspective, it was
flawless.
Um the candidate was looped for 40
minutes
in the assessment and we received the
feedback from his side, not from the
monitoring system. Oh, wow. But
doesn't that mean that you have just
insufficient monitoring? Not necessarily
insufficient, but insufficiently
calibrated. In agentic systems,
observability does not mean logging
actions. It means logging the reasoning,
what the agent observed, what plan it
formed, why it choose action X instead
of action W.
So, why not only log actions?
Because you will see that everything
went fine. Green dashboard, zero errors.
But if you log the reasoning, you see
that the agent made a decision based on
a scenario that nobody had anticipated
and the difference between the two is
the difference between a system you
control and one that merely appears to
be working.
That sounds like an enormous volume of
logging. Is that technically feasible?
You do not need to log everything. You
log at the checkpoints. So, think of
it in to this way. If we have an agentic
flow from with 10 to 15 steps, you do
not need logging at every step. You need
it at the decision points, where the
agent choose a path, not where it simply
execute an instruction.
And you need an end-to-end trace ID that
allows you to reconstruct the entire
decision chain after the fact.
That is not an implementation detail. It
is the minimum requirement for an
agentic system in production.
So,
let's talk more about this gray zone
that you call behavioral validation. You
mentioned that it sits at a crosswalk
between product definition, product
testing, and product development.
Um,
who is responsible for it? Everyone.
And that is the problem. Okay.
Traditionally, development builds,
testers test, and uh, product defines,
yeah? In agentic AI, those boundaries no
longer hold clearly, and I will let you
know why.
Because an agent is not just code. It is
code that makes decisions.
And um, those decisions
must be validated, not just technically,
but also semantically, and from a
business perspective, and no single team
can do that alone.
Okay, so as a product manager, that
sounds great in theory, but in practice,
how do I convince a developer to sit in
the same room with myself and somebody
from the business side to discuss
behavioral evaluations?
You show them why it is necessary. Okay.
And the best argument, it's a real
failure.
We had a situation with an agent that
was producing strategic decisions for
manufacturing.
It correctly detected a major anomaly,
a significant spike in the data, yeah?
It labeled it correctly. Everything was
technically perfect. And uh, the
problem, for that specific label, there
was no decision fallback. Nobody had
modeled the scenario. The downstream
agent, the one making the strategic
decisions,
received a valid label
for which it had no instruction. And it
made a decision.
A decision in order in the order of
hundreds of millions of euros.
It was strategically completely wrong,
but it was not a bug. It was not a
hallucination. It was a lack of
behavioral modeling, a real scenario
that nobody had anticipated. And who
should have anticipated a scenario?
This is a key question, and the answer
is the team, not one person. And that is
why I insist on cross-functional
collaboration. The solution of this
issue, or this
bug, let's say, it's the agent
orchestration flow, the complete flow of
decisions that an agent or a system of
agents makes must be built with the
rigor of a contract, and it's a flow
contract. It's not um technical
artifact, it's a product artifact.
Business people know which scenarios are
critical. Product people know um
what experience it's acceptable.
Developers know how to uh what it's
technically feasible, and the testers
know how to find the gaps. So, if you do
not have all of them to the same table
in the same room, you will always have
blind spots.
Okay, so what's the role of an architect
in this whole landscape?
Am I guessing it right that the
architect is playing the role of
facilitator in this scenario?
Yes, in 2026, the AI architect is not um
in place just to uh draw diagrams, yeah?
So, the the role is more complex because
you need to bring the people to the same
table and to discuss what that really
matters, to connect the dots. The
question it's very important how you ask
the correct questions, yeah? So, instead
of asking how to build something, an
application, an agentic system,
something that you can find out on the
internet very easily and with a little
bit of practice, you will know what to
choose. The correct
question is more like
what we are expecting from this agent
when something goes wrong
>> or fails exactly or it's not as not in
acceptance criteria, let's say. Mhm.
Yeah, you understood right.
You mentioned principles, so let's get
specific. What principles do you apply?
Yes, I have a few that I have learned
the even into the hard way. So, uh the
most important for me always design for
failure.
Um
Remember that the failure is never a
single event in uh an agentic system.
The worst-case scenario is not a failed
request, it's a chain of wrong
decisions, each build on the previous
one,
each amplifying the error before it.
And uh an agent does not fail in
isolation. An agent it's failing in
cascade.
That sounds alarming. So, how do you
contain that cascading? Through
boundaries.
And that leads to the second principle
that I have clearly defined what is
input data, what are the instructions,
and where the boundaries are. An agent
operates within um three spaces.
What is told to do, what it what it
received as data, and what is forbidden
from doing.
When you blur those uh spaces,
the most serious problems emerge.
Blur them how? Who blurs them?
Sometimes we do as a team, but sometimes
someone else
does it deliberately.
And that is less obvious part when
external data can contain instructions,
an email, a document, a webpage, even
advertising,
anything that and everything that enters
in the agent context can be
intentionally
crafted to alter its behavior. It is
called prompt injection. Everyone knows
about it. It's not theoretically, it's
real, it's in production, and it's
various.
And
how do you prepare the system for scale
in this case? Because we are talking
about multiple and multiple possible
failure points, right?
Yes, this is the third principle
basically
stress constantly. Multi-agent increase
complexity exponentially. And before you
add another agent, you really need to
know
if the that agent, that new agent, it's
mandatory. Maybe a normal workflow or a
back-end solution it's enough, yeah? So,
we are not adding multiple agents if
they're not really
mandatory. Every new agent is an
additional point of failure, a source of
latency, and
an entity that can make decisions that
contradict the rest of the of the
system.
Okay, but however, we are moving into
multi-agents setups, environments,
spaces. Yes. yes. And I'm not so saying
you should not use them. Yeah,
I'm saying you should be aware of what
you are taking on.
When you have multiple agents, the agent
orchestration flow grows. Not
exponentially, but grows a lot. And for
now we are not able every time to stay
in the same room to collaborate. And
of course, you need to take this into
consideration.
Each agent has an own decision, its own
states, its own failure notes. The the
combinations
explode. That is why I insist that the
flow must be treated as a contract,
built, validated, and signed by the
entire team. It is the only way of
capturing the complexity.
You mentioned something interesting
earlier.
You said that an agent doesn't know what
it does not know. So, can you expand on
that? Yes, maybe is the most
underestimated aspect. Unlike a human
who senses uncertainty, a language model
produce output with the same fluency and
the same confidence tone regardless of
whether it has a solid information or
just making things up. And there is no
natural signal for I do not know. So,
you as the architect need to define when
the agent must stop and ask for
clarification. We are using basically a
tool inside the plot prompt request
clarification. Yeah, you explicitly
instruct it is better to ask than to
guess.
That's it. So, sounds simple. In
practice, it's easy,
but it's easy also to forget or to
um
to say it's too hard to to test.
Okay.
I'm smiling because I'm just remembering
about the question about how many hours
are in strawberry, so yeah. Um but what
you said um sounds quite difficult to
test. So, how do you test it? Because uh
from my point of view that doesn't fit
into a unit test.
It does not. And uh this brings us back
to the importance of cross-functional
collaboration. Product people know
um what questions the agent should be
asking. Developers know how to implement
the the mechanism, and the testers know
how to simulate uncertainty. Uh
so no one of from these perspectives can
or it's sufficient on on its own.
And this validation is not one um
time effort. Um it is continuous as as
you discover new scenarios in production
almost
each month. I will I will not say each
day.
I was thinking about every day.
So, let us take one step back.
Let's say somebody who is listening
right now is at the stage of building an
MVP uh for an agentic system. What would
be top three things that they need to
keep into account while building it?
First, do not wait for production to
discover how your agent uh behaves. Put
it in front of real users as fast as
possible. 10 users are enough. You don't
need uh more. You don't need it to make
it at scale.
10 users will you will find more from
them than from 500 tests, yeah? So, it's
really a game-changer.
Second, um build semantic fallbacks uh
mechanism, not just technical ones,
yeah? It is not enough to catch um the
exception and retry. You need to define
what the agent does when it receives
something valid but unexpected.
Exception caught, fallback executed,
conversation continues. Sounds great,
but in a log.
Um if the user is stuck for 40 minutes
in a loop, you have a business problem,
not an infrastructure one. And the
third, the agent state leaves outside
the model. An LLM is stateless by the
nature. If progress, uh intermediate
decisions, and relevant context uh live
only in the prompt, they will be lost or
distorted over time. So, you need an
external state store. Um and you need to
save the progress at every important
checkpoint. Otherwise, um
I like to say that you will have an
amnesiac with permissions. An amnesiac
with permissions, that's quite vivid.
Yes, but it's accurate. So, an agent
that does uh
doesn't know what has done and has
permissions to execute to keep acting,
it's exactly that. It's an amnesiac with
permissions.
All right. Um
so, to summarize up until now, right? We
talked about
how to design, how to think, what to do
at MVP stage. Now, if we are to think
about
behaviorally validating
all of these aspects, how do you do
that? How do you measure it also?
Hopefully, everyone uh knows the the
good exor from the technical side, yeah?
So, I'm talking here about evaluations,
um evals.
And this is the loop that close
everything we have
just discussed. All of this
cross-functional work, the conversations
with the business, the scenarios from
the product, the edge cases discovered
in in production, does not stay on a
whiteboard. It turns into concrete
evaluations. Every behavioral scenario
you identify becomes an eval
that you run,
measure, and track over time.
So, aren't evals just tests, then?
Not in the traditional sense. A
technical test verifies, "Did the agent
return a valid JSON?" Yes, no, yeah. A
behavior behavioral eval verifies, "Did
the agent make the right decision in
this specific context? Did it know when
to stop? Did it ask for clarification
when it should have? Did it stay aligned
with the original objective after 15
steps?" Yeah. So, these are the things
you cannot verify with a unit test. And
those scenarios come exactly from the
collaboration we have been talking about
today.
In practice, the process looks like you
collaborate cross-functional to identify
what you should be validating. You turn
those scenarios into evals. You run the
eval evals continuously,
not once, but at every iteration, yeah.
Every model change, every prompt
modification that you have
done.
That is the bridge. That is how you go
from I hope it works to I know it works,
and I can prove it. And this is also one
of the way into which you can give the
assurance, yeah.
Agent insurance. Can you insure an
agent? And what's the relationship
between insurance agent insurance
actually and eval's?
Yes.
So, what we are making normally with
evaluations, we are controlling we are
giving the stability and the speed of
our agents, yeah. We are controlling
them. Um now there is uh these
certifications
of the agents of of the companies that
are producing uh agents, yeah. And what
is required? Risk quantification,
predictability, and audit. How you are
giving this? With evaluations. Not the
only thing, yeah, required for the
certification, but three very important
characteristics
with which you can ensure that your
agent is doing something specifically.
That's very interesting. This sounds
like the next step in the evolution of
agentic systems.
>> Yes. Uh we invent them, we build them,
we scale them, and now we are ensuring
that they are making what are supposed
to do.
Okay, so looks like we've got a lot of
work to do. Now, the question is when
and how will we achieve it?
I'm talking about that big amount of
work that we need to do in order to
really build robust agentic systems.
Yes. When? Each day, yeah.
Uh with what?
We are using AI tools and I'm happy to
say that sometimes we receive help or we
improve our pace with even 50%.
Sometimes it's not 50, it can be a 30,
it's the most common, let's say, but
with really difficult things or complex,
better to say, things to implement, um
even with 10% we are happy. It's help
that it's required because exactly like
you said, the amount of work, the amount
of things that almost each day we need
to come back and to add and not because
the system was not correct, but for the
system to be correct also in the future,
in the near future. The things are
evolving into
Uh, yeah, the pace is incredible. I'm
I'm very happy actually that I'm living
this this period, yeah. So,
we are coming to an end.
But if you had to leave the audience
with some thoughts, what would those be?
Technically we can build anything,
almost anything right now. That is no
longer the the challenge. The challenge
is that what we have built behave
correctly. When we plan
no longer holds. And
you do not learn that from the
architecture. You do not learn it from
the pipelines or you don't learn it from
the green dashboards.
You learn it only by putting the agent
in front of reality and having the right
people in the room when things breaks.
And
even better, if it's possible, before
the things to break.
So, what if that doesn't happen?
They have an amnesiac with permissions
in production and
they will find out from from their
users, not from their monitoring. I
really hope that we are improving the
way in which we are using the
evaluations. Everyone is doing them,
don't get me wrong. But there is a super
super fine line between just having
evaluations and having the correct ones.
I see. So, perhaps some closing thoughts
here would be that perhaps everyone
should think about what questions to ask
their agent.
Yes. You want to thank you very much.
Thank you, Yana.